>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Anne McLean: Good evening.
I'm Anne McLean.
I'd like to welcome all of
you on behalf of the Library
of Congress Concert Office and also
the Poetry and Literature Center.
Tonight we're delighted
to be presenting the world
premier performance of a work
by Michael Hersch, performed
by members of the Atos Trio,
titled "Carrion-Miles to Purgatory:
13 Pieces After Texts
of Robert Lowell".
His composition for violin and
piano -- sorry, violin and cello,
is a commission from the Library's
Hans Kindler Foundation Trust Fund.
We're very pleased to have
Michael with us tonight,
and fortunate to be able to present
him as a speaker in conversation
with psychologist and
author Kay Redfield Jamison.
This premier is an
important feature in our rich
and very diverse 2015-16 lineup.
A wonderful season that
celebrates our 90 years
as a vibrant concert
presenter on the world stage.
For the music division,
it's a great pleasure
to see this commission
came into being.
Michael Hersch is internationally
admired as the distinguished
and thoughtful composer and pianist.
In our program tonight you can read
several comments about his career
and there are wealth of
statements that you can find online
and in the literature by
critics and commentators
that attest to his stature.
The Financial Times of London
states that he is considered "one
of the most fertile and musical
minds to emerge in the U.S.
over the past generation."
And The Baltimore Sun talks
about music of "stark, settling,
seemingly implausible beauty."
I won't mention the prizes and
awards, but you can see them
in tonight's program and
it's an impressive list.
I would also like to
acknowledge three guests
that we are very delighted
to welcome this evening
Dr. Ronald Daniels,
President of The Johns Hopkins
University, and his wife,
Joanne Rosen, and Dean Frederick
Bronstein from Peabody Conservatory.
It's unusual to find the
leading research institution
of global repute with the rare
attribute of being home to one
of the world's leading
conservatories.
Tonight's free concert
presentation definitively points
up the commitment of these
institutions to a philosophy
of creative and provocative
interdisciplinary ventures.
In especially resonant confluence
for our own institution, Dr. Jamison
and Michael Hersch will be talking
about work of Robert Lowell,
who was the Library's
Poet Laureate Consultant
in Poetry in 1947 and 1948.
Kay Jamison is the Dalio Family
Professor in Mood Disorders,
Professor of Psychiatry at the
Johns Hopkins University School
of Medicine, and co-director of the
Johns Hopkins Mood Disorders Center.
She's an acknowledged international
authority on depressive illnesses.
Also, she is a good friend
to the Library of Congress,
convening in 2008 a very successful
Music and the Brain Speaker Series,
which is still very much
in circulation online.
Dr. Jamison is also a
Robert Lowell scholar
and will shortly be publishing
a book about the poet.
Afterwards, she will
be in the lobby.
You can great her and I
wanted to say that we are --
we have for sale copies of
her book "Touched With Fire:
Manic-Depressive Illness and
the Artistic Temperament".
Please welcome Kay Redfield Jamison.
[ Applause ]
>> Kay Redfield Jamison: Thank you.
It's wonderful to be back at the
Library of Congress, a great,
great place, and an honor to be on
the same platform as Michael Hersch.
Robert Lowell was born
into a prominent New
England family in 1917.
He was a poet of great
originality and huge influence
in American poetry and
Western poetry in general.
He was twice awarded the Pulitzer
Prize for Poetry and, as Anne said,
in 1947 and 1948 he was a
Consultant in Poetry here
at the Library of Congress.
That was the early title for
Poet Laureate of United States.
Lowell suffered throughout
his life from manic-depressive
or bipolar illness, from a
particularly terrible form of it
and was hospitalized for
mania nearly 20 times.
He died in 1977, at the age of 60.
So, I'm gonna talk just for a
little while, for a few minutes
about Robert Lowell and his poetry,
and then a little bit about some
of the overlapping similarities
between Robert Lowell
and Michael Hersch.
Not the mental illness
side of things,
but the genius side of things.
And then, Michael and I are
going to talk, not so long,
because we'd like to leave it
open for a lot of questions.
"Darkness honestly lived
through is a place of wonder
and life," Robert Lowell wrote.
"So much has come from there."
It was October 1957, and he was
40 years old, writing poetry
like a house on fire, and taking
darkness into a new country.
It was, he said, the best
writing he had ever done.
His new work became the
heart of life studies,
described by one critic as "the
most influential book of poetry
since T.S. Eliot's 'The Waste
Land.'" The poems, most written well
and in few months time,
left their mark.
"They have made a conquest,"
wrote The Reviewer.
"They have won a major expansion
of the territory of the poetry."
In December 1957, after a summer
and fall blaze of writing,
Lowell was admitted to
psychiatric hospital in Boston.
He was psychotic, manic, insane.
It was his fifth psychiatric
hospitalization in 8 years.
These were long hospitalizations,
not like our modern hospitalizations
where people get admitted and leave
almost as soon as they get admitted.
Oh, these were hospitalizations
of many months.
These were severe manias, where he
would be put in straight jacket,
taken in hospital by six or
seven Boston police officers.
Lowell told the doctor
who admitted him
that the preceding
months had been some
of the most productive
months of his writing poetry.
It was a pattern he had come to know
well - first the weeks of intense,
fiery writing, then the spike
in the mania, and finally,
as night follows day, the dusts
in the blood of depression.
The psychiatrist wrote in
Lowell's medical chart what many
of his doctors were to observe.
"The patient's had a series
of breaks," she wrote,
"all in light of unusual
literary output."
Much had come from the
darkness, but not without a cost.
Mania and imagination
many times come together
to help create great art.
But disciplining character
makes art from inborn gift.
"Poetry may come from a unhappy and
disordered life," Lowell once wrote,
"but a huge amount of health
has to go into the misery."
Without question, Lowell's attacks
of mania splurged some
of his finest works.
They also brought great pain
to him and to those he loved.
Things he had done, when he was
manic, haunted him when he was well.
He was mortified and ashamed.
So too did his terror that he
would become psychotic again.
Yet, Lowell came back from madness
time and time and time again,
re-entered the fray and
kept intact his friendships.
He kept his wit, he
kept his capacity
to love, he went back to work.
This faculty for regeneration is
not a common one, nor is the courage
to face and to rate from the
certainty of impending madness.
Courage is unusual.
So too is creating poetry
that expands the territory.
Lowell's poetic imagination
was tethered to an unstable,
but fiercely disciplined mind.
It forged his work and
it branded his life.
"When I'm dead," Lowell
once told a friend,
"I don't care what
you write about me.
All I ask is that it be serious."
Lowell's seriousness of purpose
was matched by a vaulting ambition,
that had been his since childhood.
It was a desire and a capacity
for rashness, ambition,
the great sweep of great ideas.
It was something he
admired in other writers.
"Melville and Hawthorne he loved,"
Lowell once wrote, "pour out more
than the measure will hold.
What wonderful dangers,
errors, condescensions
and breathless abundance."
Lowell, Hawthorne,
Melville, Whitman --
all like Coleridge were
habituated to the vast.
They swung for the fences.
They wrote to change the game.
Many of Lowell's early poems,
including several of those chosen
as texts for this evening's
music by Michael Hersch,
are dominated by themes of
moral decay, of pain, suffering,
a fallen New England, retribution,
and the unforgiving
puritanism of his ancestors.
He wrote of the complex
burden of heritage
and of the dark, ambiguous
grace of God.
The battle that raged between
Calvinism, his native tongue,
the New England protestantism
that he had known longest
and breathed most deeply, and
the catholicism that he had
as an adult taken to heart
and mind, and then quit,
was one that was reflected
in part in his mental wars.
It was a clash that entered into his
work violently and unforgettably,
in his early poems, work that
the most influential critic
of the time said would be read
as long as men remember English.
These were poems of ambition, elegy
and blood, coiled and unstable
in force and fury, and
crafted with brilliance.
Lowell's great poem "The
Quaker Graveyard in Nantucket,"
which Michael Hersh has drawn
from this evening, in part,
was a debt to Melville and The Old
Testament, to Thoreau, to Hopkins.
It is Homeric in force, mythic in
scale and spelled by the violence
of God in Lowell's home
North Atlantic waters.
It is the battleground
for the contrasting forces
that defined his mind
as a young poet.
The poem, as Seamus Heaney said,
is one where "the percussion
and brass section of the
language orchestra is driven hard"
and "the string section
hardly gets a look-in."
Michael Hersch has essential things
in common with Robert Lowell.
He's an unrelenting
way serious artist.
His work is rooted in a profound
knowledge of grief and death
and life of the human condition,
in art, literature and in music.
He has, like Lowell, a
restless, tectonic imagination
and the courage of his beliefs.
He takes risks.
Lowell, it is always said, and there
is somebody who is writing a book
about him, it is the first thing
if anybody has actually heard
of Lowell, the first
thing that people say is,
"He is a really difficult poet."
Lowell is a difficult poet.
It's part of what makes him great.
So too is Michael a
difficult composer.
His work is complex,
unpredictable, dark, and wonderful.
It is beautiful.
It is piercingly human.
And I am honored to be
here with him tonight.
[ Applause ]
>> Kay Redfield Jamison:
Please just sit.
We're going to just
keep this very informal.
So, why Lowell?
>> Michael Hersch: You know,
when -- I've always been drawn,
especially since I
got out of school,
I tend to find much more inspiration
and more friendship, if you will,
and camaraderie and company in text,
whether it's literary or poetical.
There's very little of it that
jumps out and grabs hold of me
in that way, I think, that
all artists are looking
for on some level, where
we react very strongly
to when we see something of
ourselves somewhere else.
I don't make any presuppositions
or suppositions
about what Lowell meant,
felt, any of these things.
But it doesn't change
the fact that in a lot
of his work I saw something
of myself.
Then, again, I understand that's
one to zero correspondance,
it's all in my own mind, in my
own sensibility or sensitivity.
But when I started
combing through his work,
sometimes it's just a word.
It's often not more than a word or
a pair of words or trio or quartet
of words, or maybe a phrase.
Very rarely will it be an
entire tract of poetry.
These are the things that
ignite something in me.
It's incredibly exciting, it's
a feel like there's someone
who saw the world through
similar eyes,
even though the experiences
couldn't be more different.
And in a way, it doesn't really
matter to me what it is that he saw.
It's how I perceive it on the page,
what's real and what's in front
of me - an abstract biography.
And so, like all the arts and
literature and poetry and music
that I respond to, there was
something there that just touched
to the merrow of what it is
that I'm looking for in art.
And then in turn it has an impact
in one way or another on things
that I attempt to make myself.
>> Kay Redfield Jamison: So, of
all of his poetry, which is huge
and collected verse of his,
you focus on the early poems?
Was that because there was such
a long collection of poetry
to read through or was it --
>> Michael Hersch: No, I think there
was something actually in what I do.
If anybody ever went through all
of my books, you might take a book
of the shelf that contains some
of the most consequential material
in terms of material that I've
somehow had a conversation with,
in service of literature
or poetry, through music.
But often times, if someone
looked at one of those books,
they wouldn't notice anything in it.
They have to look very carefully,
because it would be two words
on this page, and then 60 pages
later there may be a sentence here
and another 45 pages
later something else.
It's incredibly specific to me and
there is oftentimes no real method
or obvious methodology to how
I'm engaging with these texts.
So that was really notable
and, in Lowell's case,
that terrain of the expression
that I was feeling myself,
looking for companionship and
certain text fragments came to mind.
So, when I was writing this music,
I started the music before I went
to the Lowell, but certain text
fragments of Lowell came to mind.
Maybe one of the first was a line in
poem; it's just something as simple
as "Canaries beat their
bars and scream",
and that just popped into my mind.
Or, another image of two
angels fighting over the soul
of the man with billhooks.
These kinds of images that were
just incredibly searing images
and I would just be writing and
then they would come to mind
and then I would go and try to track
down where did I remember that from?
And sometimes there would be
musical allusions to leave talk --
there is a rhyme where he talks
about hell being burned out
and heaven's harps-strings
going slack.
And then somehow these all start
to tie together, to tailor together
and ultimately it makes sense -
they were from the same collection.
But that surprised me, because
usually people are trying
to make sense of what
the relationships are
between different text fragments.
But in this case it was
very clean that way.
But that just speaks to the
consistency of rendering
of his own imagination at that time.
>> Kay Redfield Jamison: Right,
anything that would have exist
very clear and fascinating
about Lowell is he's one of these
writers, rather like Beethoven,
who just moved from effort.
He just moved and changed
and went on and recreated,
and so that Lord Weary's Castle,
which is made of mostly fragments,
is completely different from so
much of the work he did after that.
So, very, very different.
>> Michael Hersch: Yes, and
there's no real explanation as to --
the interesting thing -- really,
it's not so interesting --
is that I'm not looking for
something that is trying
to capture a sort of
emotional or psychological --
there's something that's
going to click
with a feeling, with that feeling.
I'm not after an image
and I think that's one
of the complicating factors
in a piece like this.
I'm certainly not the first person
to engage with text this way,
but a lot of times
people like the idea.
It's a very clean idea to take
an image that's laid out in words
that we all understand and then
the idea of composer taking that
and trying to render that or
transform that into sound.
That's too fastle.
I don't know if that's
the right use of the word.
It's more nuance than that.
These images are a byproduct
of something that's a feeling,
a state of mind, a state of being.
I think that one of the things
that's extraordinary about Lowell is
that he's able to take
something as simple as an image,
though, and capture that.
That's a very hard thing to do.
I found that for me, what was
different about these texts
versus others is how visual they
are, or to me they are visual.
>> Kay Redfield Jamison: He
described capturing experience
in talks, you know, and
you would look at them.
I think one of his famous
images was meat-hooked --
words "meat-hooked
from the living steer."
I mean, it's that incredibly
graphic imagery that, you know,
you have to have a heart of stone
to remain unresponsive to, I think.
>> Michael Hersch: Yeah, yeah.
No, I --
>> Kay Redfield Jamison:
Do you see anything kind
of intrinsically musical
about Lowell's work?
I mean, by definition poetry is
musical, but is there anything
that sets him apart in that?
>> Michael Hersch: You know, for
me what's interesting is most
of the texts that I've ended up
connecting really strongly with me
over my life - they
tend to be texts written
in non-English languages
and they're translated.
Sometimes I can handle
the original languages,
but in the end I'm the product
of English and the admiration
that I have and the
gratitude that I have
for great translators
can't be overstated.
Of course, Lowell translated
as well.
So, what was interesting was along
with just a few other people
here was some writing in English.
So there's just something
inherently musical to me
about seeing these thoughts, these
feelings, these recollections,
these terrors, these premonitions,
whatever you might
call them, in English.
They were originally
conceived in English and,
because that's my language,
that's the language I'm
most comfortable with,
there's something inherently
musical to me.
That's not answering your
question exactly, but yes,
I do find there's something
particularly musical
about these words and the way
that they are laid out on page.
But, of course, in this case I'm
not setting any of these words.
I just told someone earlier
that I've written a lot of music
that has relationships with
text in one way or another.
Just like this piece -
it accompanies the piece
in a certain way, but
it's comunication more
between me and the writer.
But I think this piece, more
than any other that I've done,
I do feel it's, if not necessary,
than important for people,
when they're listening to the music,
to read the accompanying text.
Again, in the past I would have
felt that there had not been --
the texts certainly don't
need my music and I would hope
that the music doesn't need any text
that may have accompanied
me personally
on the journey of writing.
But in this case, I think
that they are very unified
in a way that's much
more pronounced and so,
in this case I encourage
people to read and listen.
>> Kay Redfield Jamison: I think
that Lord Weary's Castle is just
so marked by movement and energy and
force and madness, it just moves.
There's something, there's a
velocity to Lord Weary's Castle
that is not unlike
his subsequent work,
but it's much much more pronounced.
>> Michael Hersch: Yes, I would
agree there's an immediacy to it
that it compels itself, I'd say even
in small fragments it does that.
I think for me in all art, whether
it's a building, a sculpture,
a painting, a poem, a novel -
something for me that's
important is a sense of momentum.
You can achieve momentum in absolute
stasis and never have anything other
than absolute stasis, and there
still can be a shocking momentum
to it.
I think he achieves that, he
definitively achieves that kind
of momentum, whatever he's
doing, when he's at his best.
>> Kay Redfield Jamison: I
think it's sure and I think one
of the things is striking in his
work is this change over time.
But that incredible rhythm,
particularly in the early works -
it's the sea over and over again,
or it's a turmoil of people over
and over again, but it's
in waves, unremitting.
>> Michael Hersch: One thing
I thought was interesting was
when I realized how relatively
young he was when he wrote,
as I was becoming very not
relatively young anymore.
It always struck me as a bit
odd that I was drawn to be
where he was, in his light.
There's that period in all of
our lives, whatever is happening,
that's always a bit tempestuous and
on some level I was puzzled by this.
But what's interesting is that for
him that was his life, at the time.
For me, life -- for all
of us as we get older --
becomes defined more and
more by advance and actions
and things that have boundaries.
Sometimes these boundaries
become unclear
or broken and then they spill.
But it was interesting how
something that very clearly
for him was all-encompassing, a sort
of his state of mind over a period
of years, applied so nicely
to something where I was put
in this state of mind of
something very specific
that does recapture the sort of
generic trauma of being younger.
In this case it was real traumas
and so I was able to take something
that on the surface didn't
seem to match so much
with where I was in my life.
But then taken and put inside,
encapsulated in a series of events
in my life, it actually
worked really nicely.
I'm only thinking about
this right now,
I haven't actually thought
too much about that.
So, in that sense, the period in his
life is not really relevant to me.
Many artists have done a lot
of great things at that period,
it's not such an extraordinary
age to do the work.
But there's a totality to
his state of mind and a sort
of all-encompassing-ness to that
state of mind that he's able
to sustain without seeming like --
he's able to avoid these traps that
lot of people, when we're younger,
fall into - self-pity or
just sort of undefined angst.
It just translates so nicely to
real world of grown up things
that are defined in advance,
and in that sense it's
that mature level that's
quite extraordinary, I think.
>> Kay Redfield Jamison: Gee, can
you write a chapter for my book?
That's very good.
That's very true.
I think too, with Lowell,
as you say,
he was 29 when he got Pulitzer
Prize for his body of work.
By that time he had been
through just an incredible
series of life-times.
I think partly he was born
tempestuous and he died tempestuous,
but this was a period of
time that was just striking
for the changes in
his emotional being.
And then in just a few years time
that he would be hospitalized
for the first time for mania.
But you can feel the mania
in the work and certainly
in the lines of the works.
I think what's also interesting
is that, not unlike many people,
of course, he had great love for
music and he wrote about music.
So he wrote a sonnet
about [inaudible],
a sonnet about the Archduke trio
that's being played tonight.
He wrote sonnets about
Beethoven, Schubert,
the two great composers
that he most loved.
There was something always
in the back of his mind
that you had the sense
was being formed by music,
his being classicist by
education and training and heart.
By other poets, by
other writers, by love.
I mean, this is hugely
broad and not this kind
of picky or manicured life that -
>> Michael Hersch: You know, he
seemed to me looked around him
and he had that sense, you know.
And, you know, and
it's - I knew the --
for me, you know, I feel
that all the early years
that I was composing, certainly
through my late teens and 20s,
I didn't feel like I had
my head above the clouds,
until I got on the far side of 25.
I just feel like there was
so much I just wasn't seeing
and for me it took some time.
It took me into, such
as read something
where someone had this sort
of control of his materials
and had a sense of
what was around them.
I don't mean sense of
influence, I mean just a sense
of the human landscape
that surrounded him.
I feel like I'm still
noticing things.
We all of us are going to
notice things hopefully always,
but what was interesting just
looking back from that perspective,
to be able to see someone
who had figured that out
and there was a clarity of
thought in a relatively young age.
Well, I was sure that I had
that clarity of thought then,
but it's interesting and a lot
of times I've found that writers
and poets have that clarity
of thought before musicians.
I don't know why that may be.
I don't know if I have any clarity
of thought yet, but there's sense
of one's self changes and the
sense of being in the dark.
But he just had this sort of
omniscience that comes through.
Whether it was real or not, it is a
sort of force of personality also.
And I think that's also one of
things that characterizes him -
the force of his personality
just comes
through very strongly
from very early on.
And that's a rare thing.
>> Kay Redfield Jamison: You see,
he once quoted about John Berryman,
who was similarly forceful and
manic, that there was no one
so loyal as John, but you'd like
to have him living in another city.
There is that element
of pure intensity,
but I think it's also true that
people who knew him very well
and who loved him very much also
describe this incredible gentleness.
So it's always, he's
opposing sort of forces
of just incredible
gentleness and kindness
and talkingness and soft-spokenness.
He's a calm, good man.
So, what about the writing of
it and the words and the music,
and then maybe open
it up to questions.
>> Michael Hersch: I mean,
there's really not much to say.
The piece, you can read in the notes
or everybody has, is in 13 movements
and the piece just
unfolds on it's own.
It is what it needs to be,
what I made improvising it
a lot in the coming weeks.
This particular piece was
writing for violin and cello.
I've found it difficult, but it
was a real sort of metal testing,
it was -- the two instruments
I feel very close to,
but I've never written just
for the two of them together.
And so there was a lot of --
the Lowell's text provided some of
these landscapes that he provided
in my own mind, create certain
sonorities or certain sounds that --
but all kinds of things
are going into writing it,
that I don't know how important
it is for people to really know.
It's like looking at the wiring
or the piping of the building.
>> Kay Redfield Jamison: Maybe
a little bit more than that.
>> Michael Hersch: How does that
reiterate what I've said before?
That more than any other piece
that I've written that is engaged
with text, where the
text is not song.
It's essential to this piece.
This piece wouldn't have been
written had I not been engaging
with these texts.
As I said before, the fact that
so many of them just came to mind
in an involuntary sort of way speaks
to how important they were to me,
or have been, maybe
without even knowing it.
So, even on some level it
may even be OK to refer
to these center pieces as a
kind of songs without words.
Except that the words are there,
but they're just not song.
>> Kay Redfield Jamison: Thank you.
Just open up for questions?
Yes?
>> What prompted this
particular choice of pieces?
>> Michael Hersch:
That was just simply
when the Library approached me.
They wanted something
that had featured cello,
so normal thing would
probably be to do a sonata
for piano or maybe a solo cello.
But after thinking about that -- I
had to think about it for a while,
and if I hadnt, you know, even
with this incredibly generous
opportunity, exciting opportunity,
I still needed to feel - I have
to feel excited about if I'm going
to undertake any kind of project.
At a bare minimum, I have to be
excited about the possibility
of writing for whatever
the medium is.
And so I went to them and I said
that it would be a bit unorthodox
perhaps, but would they allow me
to write something for violin
and cello, so they said, "yes."
So that's all.
>> What did Lowell die of --
what did Lowell die of again?
>> Michael Hersch: She wants to
know what he died -- how he died.
>> Kay Redfield Jamison: This is
the composer's daughter, Abby.
Abby Hersch.
We're delighted you're here.
Mr. Lowell died of a lot things, but
I would actually turn to my husband,
who's a cardiologist and
who's doing that side
of the work, but he died of?
>> He died of a heart attack.
>> Kay Redfield Jamison: Yes.
After years of 4-5 packs
a day of cigarettes,
not inconsiderable amount
of drinking, and mania,
which actually elevated
rate for heart disease.
So he was under intense stress,
so it was a culmination of things.
And both of his parents had
heart disease, so he was living
under shadows of disease.
Great question.
>> Hi, I'm trying to see if I can
put this into words, my question,
but as Dr. Jamison said,
Lowell was very difficult,
just reading this here.
And it seems more -- what
struck me about it is
that it's more a collection of
impressions than it does draw
on a single visual
descriptive kind of thing.
So if it is a collection
of impressions, I wonder,
in reading this it would call
to mind either ideas or images,
and which of them will help me
to better understand the music?
>> Michael Hersch:
If it's the music --
if I've succeeded in any way in
writing what I hoped to write,
then you hopefully won't need help,
there shouldn't be anything
referential that you have to do.
So, when I say it's good
to have those texts there,
it's like having a passing glance.
You can read them all at once
and not look at them again,
you can read -- usually I'm
antagonistic towards the idea
of reading and listening: I
think listening requires all
of our faculties and any
distraction is not a good thing.
So, I guess my expectation would
just be that if you listen to it
and you have a certain
reactions and you read the text,
you might just kind of, say
-- you would just sort of nod,
there would be some sense that
there was a rightness to it.
And if there wasn't, that
can be expected, too.
But, again, I just want
to reiterate that I hope
that the music doesn't
need the poetry.
I know that those texts
don't need my music.
That's for sure.
I just think that the presence of
those texts, perhaps, might heighten
or augment the experience
of listening to music
through their proximity -
meaning them being on the tip
of your mind if you read.
You might just recognize
something of each and in each pole,
the literary or the
poetical or the music,
that there's some common
ground there.
I think, frankly, for people who
don't have a lot of experience
with musical expression
that's beyond, say,
the standard repertoire, it
provides a way in, for some people.
They're hearing sounds that
they've never heard before
that and that can be jarring.
So the words can act
as a sort of bridge.
I doubt there is anybody
who can read those texts
and not have an informed
feeling about it.
For as the music, people
might listen and say,
"I'm not sure what I've heard."
Everybody's experiences are
so different with music,
but our experience with
language is pretty uniform.
And our experience with
music is uniform, too,
but every composer is
speaking in different languages
and if you have no
experience with the language,
it's probably not a bad idea to
ground oneself into it a little bit.
It doesn't mean that you
have to be liking it.
But, you see, I'm quite inarticulate
about these relationships with --
because I have never
been asked before.
So, it's okay to read
those texts, though.
>> Kay Redfield Jamison:
You might say
that there is a certain dark thread
that runs through these texts?
>> Michael Hersch: I would say
that the thread that I perceive
through those texts, that is
shared with the music, certainly.
Mainly what we're dealing
with are issues of loss,
grief and their appending
in the tentacles.
So, yes, those are the broad strokes
of expressive territory
that they share.
Again, whether I succeed
in communicating
that is certainly an
open-ended question,
but from my standpoint
those were the things
that I was trying to express.
And it seems to me
that Lowell was too.
But I'm also well aware that the
context of a lot of those poems -
that if you read them in
context, what you take away
from these fragments would
probably be unrecognizable.
So, that's a whole another thing,
which is a whole another issue,
which is for another day - whether
if it's even right for a person
to extract things like this.
To take these things out of context.
I imagine there are a lot of
people who have a real problem
with one artist, with a composer
taking fragments of a poem
which was clearly intended
to be read in it's entirety.
But, that's a risk out there.
>> Kay Redfield Jamison: Well,
apparently Lowell would not be one
of those, because he actually
was a great translator
to many perspective, but
he got huge criticism.
He took poems in languages
he didn't know,
took texts from different
language to translate from,
and then wrote his own poetry.
He saw language as living and he saw
language as - you contributed to it.
And he would be the
first, I think, to say --
>> Michael Hersch: Okay,
good, all's good to that.
>> Kay Redfield Jamison: Yes.
And he actually -- Benjamin Britton
wrote music based on Lowell's work
and he said it was one of the
greatest honors of his life.
Hhe liked the idea of
being written from.
>> Michael Hersch: That's good.
>> Michael, can you just say
something about the interplay
between the text in your
composition, as to say --
I understand that you read,
there's impressions that you take,
there's parts of the poems
that moved you and then
that inspires composition, but are
you composing, re-reading, refining
or -- can you say something
about your own creative process
in the interplay between
text and composition?
>> Michael Hersch: Yes, now that's
the part that is a bit puzzling.
It's actually -- I'll be writing
and then the words come to mind.
So, something I do
reminds me of something
that Lowell did, in this case.
Then that acts as accelerator,
somehow.
Like it then feeds whatever
it was that I was --
so, that's the part that's
a little backwards, I think.
Maybe more at expected
circumstances, where it is a sort
of you start with the
non-musical object
that then inspires
something in the composer.
The composer then -- so, that's
all something like Pictures
at an Exhibition of Mussorgsky,
that sort of basic idea, right?
He's capturing these
paintings in music.
In this case the process comes
from writing and then some
of these text writings
pop into mind.
If that happens, that's
very meaningful to me,
because there was no reason for me
to be thinking about these at all.
I'm into writing this piece, not
thinking about Lowell at all,
but from the outside, somehow, these
text fragments start to come to mind
and then I have to go
back and find them.
I stay true to what occurred to me,
that's why they are what they
exactly need to be for me.
So, sometimes all I need
is one word, it's a back
and forth in real time, sort of.
But once I've identified the
text, then that is exciting.
Then that feeds more, then
I'm getting more from that
and it might oscillate
back and forth.
So, it really is exciting, because
it's having this living dialogue.
He's not there, I'm
not talking to him,
but through his work it
really does feel very much
like collaboration,
in a strange way.
>> Lowell was glad to advise
that himself and allow images
to coagulate, so to speak?
>> Kay Redfield Jamison: Absolutely.
>> Michael Hersch: Yes.
>> There is one thing in the
program that's interesting,
they mentioned quarter tones and it
seems like in the second movement,
which also has the
word Purgatory in it,
maybe even suggesting
some sort of threshold.
Is that the only place with quarter
tones and although you're speaking
in the music, would you want
to say anything about that?
>> Michael Hersch: Yes, that is one
of the only places that I have --
there was no conscious one-to-one
correspondence between the idea
of Purgatory, but where the
quarter tones do appear,
they are very frequent in
the piece and I just think
of the quarter tone, it's
just another shade of harmony.
So, it doesn't have
any specific meaning.
Also, just for the
record, Purgatory --
I just did a song dealing with
a lot of text on Purgatory
with texts of Pound and Dante.
It's just interesting, for whatever
reason - when I was younger,
a number of the texts
that I initially read
of Dante really presented Purgatory
in a relatively beautiful and sort
of tranquil, sort of
at ease, in at ease.
That doesn't mean there's not
a sort of darkness hovering
around these things, but it's
interesting that in a lot
of Purgatory, a lot of writing
about it, the way we use it
in our common parlance
is much more grim than --
at least in my reading of
Dante or specific parts of it.
So it's very -- since
you bring up that word,
it's a very complicated
word, I mean, for me.
I mean, it has alot --
it's imbued with all kinds
of complexities and contradictions.
Anyway, but still, the
quarter tones are just
because that's what the
harmony needed in that spot.
Anything else?
No? Well, thank you very much.
It was a -- thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.